[Music]
good morning everybody and welcome to
our plans committee meeting of
thursday the 2nd december
welcome to those who may be watching on
uh tori's youtube channel
uh first out on the agenda is apologies
for absence reason of course sorry i
think we better introduce ourselves
so i will introduce the committee first
and then the officers who are present
i'm chris there then i share the
committee and i represent you all
richard wiseman i represent the champion
award
christie i represented
thank you and on my left
good morning members members of public
my name is sean hanchin and i'm managing
to council
good morning i'm stacey doyle
good morning oh my name is james jackson
i'm a principal planning officer at the
florence district council
good morning michael newcome from good
highways
thank you
okay thank you
well we've got tom though he's our
technical wiz kid
when anything goes wrong with it he's
always in spot and then sandra is out
clark
right thanks samuel
apology
thank you chair
uh one apology from councillor locke
okay we'll move on item two on the
agenda is the minute to the meeting
it was one meeting but it was over two
days on the fourth and fifth of november
2021 now pages four to 23
and i'll move those from the chair
okay
secondly
[Music]
[Music]
we're not
declarations of interest
members with interest to declare should
refer to the agenda item and describe
the nature of their interest
when the item is being considered
elected members of devon county council
and town and parish councils who've
considered a planning application by
virtue of their membership of that
council
hold a personal interest and are deemed
to have considered the application
separately
and the express views of that council do
not find the members concerned who could
consider the application fresh
item four on the agenda is agreement of
the journey between parts one and two
one with no part two
item five is urgent matters
item six is public participation
this is where i advise the committee on
the
members of the public
who want to speak at the meeting
and we've got only one application to
consider this morning
the land west of north
roadworthy councillor sue lander of the
parish council has sent a statement in
which the planning manager will need
and then we've got
mr steve smith who's objecting to it
member of the public
i'm in support we've got stephen
bainbridge the agent
and then speaking lastly but we'll take
no part in the debate and we'll be
councillor borton who's the board member
we now move on then to
planning applications at agenda item
seven
the information recommendations and
advice
contained in the reports are correct at
the date of preparation which is more
than 10 days
in advance of the committee meeting
due to these time constraints any
changes or necessary updates to the
reports will be provided in writing or
orally at the committee meeting
and as we'll move on then to application
7a
and
james jackson our plan obviously will
take this
um first of all can everyone hear me
okay yes working well today yeah okay
um so as the chair says this is um
application one slash six three two
twenty twenty one slash wtm
uh it's a major outline application for
up to 22 dwellings with all matters
reserved except access
at land west of north road bradworthy
devon
i'm just presenting this behalf of my
colleague laura davis
who's made the recommendation and
instructed the the officer's report
within your agenda
just a quick uh verbal update page 36 of
the officer's report reference is made
to an application
10162 2021 ful which is part of the
allocation
brdo2 in bradworthy um the report makes
reference to that being approved that
references um is not correct because of
the actual it was actually withdrawn um
before being determined so just
something to note there it was for seven
dwellings
um the only other update is there's an
additional condition recommended to
members
and that is a condition to secure
the footpath across the front edge of
the site
um if members were mining throughout
permission today and we're happy with
that additional condition then it's uh
recommended by our officers that the
wording is actually delegated to
officers um so then we agreed with the
chair and vice chair
um further to the committee's resolution
i imagine it would say something in the
effect of price which meant sorry prior
to the occupation of any dwelling
um a footpath shall be provided across
the frontage of the site in accordance
with details of child first have been
submitted and approved
by the local authorities that would be
the reason would be uh in the interests
of primary safety
okay next slide please sure
so this shows the site location and the
uh site is edited in red there
um to the uh west of the site you can
see land edged in blue which is uh also
within
the ownership of the applicant there's a
relatively flat site it's part of an
agricultural field
we've got existing hedgerows to the east
and the public highway beyond that
existing residential development to the
south and the built-up area is
bragworthy
we've got the remainder of the
agricultural field to the west
and to the north we have a small
agricultural building and another
agricultural field
there's also some existing residential
development to the northeast of the site
which are some farm conversions which
you can see on there as well
uh next slide picture
this just so it shows a aerial image of
the site cycle to mark with the red
arrow
you can see the sort of network of
agricultural fields within the area and
how that relates to
the built up area of bradworthy
uh the development boundary um for the
local center follows the southern part
of the site successfully wrapped around
that existing developed area
next slide usual
uh this is a photograph taken from the
existing access looking south um in the
distance there you can see
the uh existing residential development
that forms the northern part of bradwell
the developed area
please
this is in the public highway looking
south the site is on the right hand side
of that photograph on the other side of
the
of the hedgerow
in the distance you can see
existing residential development which
is again the northern part of broadway
next slide please
[Applause]
this is again looking south along the
public highway we've got the
agricultural building the small one on
the right hand side here in the
foreground uh the site is over on the
right hand side of that existing
hedgerow
and we have on the on the left hand side
um
the corner of one of the bargain
conversions and that's a small grouping
of
file conditions in residential use
looks like this
this is the photograph of the field to
the north of the site you can see that
small agricultural building on the left
hand side
and the site is on the other side of
that hedgerow
next slide please
this is just another one of the public
highway um we've got the existing
residential development in the distance
and
you can see also the existing vehicular
accesses just about where that where
that car is located
you can also see the existing
30 mile an hour
limit or the start of that which would
be relocated as part of the proposal
next slightly
okay this is just the um site plan it's
indicative only because members today
are only considering the principle of
residential use of the site and the
excess or other matters are reserved for
future consideration
it does however show a possible layout
of 22 dwellings on on the site and how
they could be accommodated we have an
attenuation pond
up in the corner of the site there in
the north western corner
as well as a new foul pumping station
there
the bottom left of the picture is an
amenity area planted out
and
obviously then a number of dwellings
shown
arranged around some internal range
uh next slide please
this just shows the proposed highway
works we've got
the existing hedge fund would be
set back
to form the visibility slaves we need 43
meters in both directions
a provision of a footpath across the
frontage of the site
and the extension of the 30 mile an hour
speed limit which would be moved
out from the village to incorporate this
this development um not listed on there
but there also would be provision for
additional street lighting um just to
which would go from the end of the
existing area of street lighting up
towards the site
this just shows the trees to be removed
there's two trees to be removed to form
the accesses visibility displays um both
trees are category c trees the the
application is accompanied by an armored
cultural
impact assessment which sort of
undertakes a survey of the entire cycle
on the
trees etc there are a couple of category
b trees as well which will be retained
as part of the development um so it's
just the two category seas
that would be lost which are in
agricultural terms are
clustered poor quality trees
uh next
this is just
from the ecology report this just shows
the habitats that would be uh that would
exist positive development really
and so we've got the
uh the attenuation pond in the north
west corner which would provide uh
biodiversity benefit
and we've also got the planted out
amenity area to
to the southern part of the site as well
uh and we've also got a number of trees
shown in terms of lining lining the
streets there on the site as well
and excited
this is just the proposed drainage
strategy the blue lines show decisions
water sewer will be a new sewer
following the um
the alignment of the of the highways
there that would discharge into the
attenuation basin into the generation
pond and then that would um in turn
viral flow control discharge to
the river walden which is over to the uh
west of the site
the red lines of the proposed bowel
water sewer that would be
uh again following alignment of the of
the internal roads that will go down to
the pumpkin station and then we can come
back to
a new connection with the existing um
foul sewer system
uh next slide visual
so main considerations for members today
the principle of development affordable
housing impacts on the landscape
character and appearance
highways and parking drainage ecology
section 106
planning balance one that's not listed
on there which would also be
consideration today is a residential
amenity um in terms of the principle the
site lies where i'm tired of the
development boundary therefore would
conflict with policy sto7
and with policy brd which is the local
spatial strategy for bradworthy
that would indicate obviously that the
principle of residential development in
that area would not normally be
supported would be unacceptable
um as members will be aware as a council
we cannot currently demonstrate a
five-year supply of housing and
therefore it's necessary to undertake
the tilted balance and
the mppf sets out a paragraph 11d that
the tilted balance requires for
permission to be granted unless the
adverse
impacts of doing so would significantly
and demonstrably acquire those benefits
so in terms of the provision of
provision of 22 dwellings
would need to be given significant
weight in your office's viewed due to
the
lack of a five-year supply
30 of those would be affordable
dwellings which would be secured by
the 106 agreement and again obviously
way in favor of
the application and sort of assist in
meeting the needs of people unable to
access open market residential
accommodation
in terms of the impact on
landscape and character
obviously we've got the reserve matters
to come in the future which would if
members were minded to approve the
application today which would uh set out
the
the uh built form and the layout etc and
also the landscaping
the site would be seen in your offices
view in the context of the existing
residential development to the south and
it's also
pertinent to note that two sites on the
opposite side of the public highway
have also been granted
planning commission
one which was on on appeal play recently
which you may have seen as well
um
there obviously would be some
localized impact in terms of the
character of the site um itself would be
altered by the development um but in
your office's view um the the impact on
the character of the wider area would
not be significant
in terms of residential amenity uh the
indicative layout shows that
the dwellings could be accommodated on
the site without significant harm to
people's amenity we've also got some
suggested conditions that amenities are
surrounding occupiers in terms of hours
of working
and there's also a condition on their
contaminated land as well
just in terms of drainage uh see we've
got no objection from the llfa
we've got a new profound water pumping
station and a surface water scheme as
well
in terms of highways we've got no
objection from the highways officer
the
development would provide appropriate
visibility displays
relocate the 30 mile an hour limit
provide a footpath across the frontage
of the site and provide additional
street lighting
in terms of biodiversity
there are a number of recommendations
within the biodiversity report to
mitigate any potential harm during the
construction phase and also in terms of
net gain
the report concludes that there will be
a 57
uh gain
in habitat units and 12 gain in petrol
units and those are derived effectively
through a to a recognized calculation
whereby you grade different
elements of the existing position and
also the proposed position and that
gives you the navigating increase
in terms of the 106 that will secure
affordable housing at 30
an education contribution towards
primary provision
and also a transport contribution
towards secondary provision
that would also secure green
infrastructure provision and and the
maintenance of that provision
and also the relocation of the 30 mile
an hour limit and the street lighting
and so in terms of um
how that weighs up in the in the playing
balance
it's your officer's view obviously that
the objections are noted to the scheme
and particularly those from the parish
council who have been feel strongly
um but in terms of that tilted balance
reason set out it is considering uh that
the the the benefits to the scheme would
be significant and would not be
significantly in
intervals um by those adverse impacts
and for that reason
uh it is your opposite view that the
application
is recommended for approval
thank you chair if there's any questions
at all then we'll see happy exams
thank you james thank you for that
presentation of that
uh my first
contribution is from the parish council
and a letter from council sue lander
which
a statement which the planning
management video
thank you for allowing blackrock council
to make representations today against
this application from 22 houses thank
you sean for reading this
we connect we cannot support this
application for many reasons
as a parish council we are reminded that
we should only consider the application
that is in front of us
for the most part we do this and we
always try to make it considered
representation when responding to
applications
therefore we ask that you consider not
just what is in front of you but the
cumulative effects the planning
applications are having on our parish
we believe that gradually has more than
to build its founding obligations in the
rural area we are a village and we want
to remain a village
we have evidence of high rail traffic
numbers in north road and the lack of
pedestrian walkways
sadly until there is an accident the
road to being safe
the unique beach trees that are being
failed to make the entrance to this
state are part of our landscape heritage
and no amount of new planting will upset
the loss of them
we are aware that housing growth should
be controlled and that president feels
that it is far from that as the
infrastructure cannot keep up
we have another planet application
graduating from 38 houses
the site layout is better the access is
better and the land use is better
it is in always a site better suited for
development than this site that you're
considering today
unfortunately that application has been
in your planning system since february
2020.
the previous planning committee granted
an earlier application on the site for
28 houses in january 2017.
then the applicant and agent the same
agent as today's applications stephanie
decided that they would try to increase
the site by ten houses
we assumed
commercial viability
so in march of this year we had
negotiating with council to reduce the
financial applications and the
affordable housing to which we strongly
objected
the principle of developing this
oversight has already been established
by the earlier application 28 houses yet
your council remains in negotiation with
the agent who would ask why
if the demand for houses and housing
demand is so high then why does that
this application not be advanced
when we asked why in today's planning
application of june this year was a 20
year planning committee ahead of this
other major application we were told
because they are still negotiating terms
from our perspective this means that we
are likely to get 60 extra hours on two
major estates
this should be one or the other not both
or preferably done at all the village
will simply not cope with this fast
increase in strengthening services our
school is overflowing and our doctor's
surgery is real capacity
we question some of the planning points
that the planning officer has considered
in reaching her recommendations for
youth grants application
there has today been no development from
the vrd02 site
two we were unaware that recent housing
needs surveyed have been undertaken
we are concerned that planning officer
has been unable to secure the precise
number of affordable dwellings on the
size of the houses
she states because it was an outline
only the precise numbers of tenure would
be secured by the planning conditions
given a lack of security tenure in a
financial viability situation with the
oversight we would have fought and
secured this was
this one was paramount
the overall situation with this
application feels hurried and unfinished
you will also see the recent planning
appeal for five houses opposite this
application
we do not believe that this appeal is a
material planning consideration
this appeal outcome and the threat of
losing another appeal could have some
financial influence on your decision
in balancing that we would say that the
council could equally face an appeal for
non-determination of the 38th house
application
the inspector's decision that the
officers committee report is subjective
when the planning officer sees enhancing
the existing services we see
overwhelmingly
if you are unable to reach the decision
on this application today would you
consider referring it into the
affordable housing and other matters
outstanding or more transparent this
could then allow the committee to
consider the application for the
application with the other applications
cyber slide
thank you for listening welcome to the
zoolander chairman of council
thank you sean
and our next speaker
to object is steve smith
under the public schools
right so we move on then so the next
speaker is in support of the application
the ancient stephen bainbridge
thank you and good morning members
thank you for inviting me to speak today
firstly i'd like to congratulate your
officer for what i think is a
comprehensive well-balanced report
although the office is not here today i
know mr jackson who's presenting is in
agreement with her recommendations i'll
support mr jackson outlined all the key
points in his presentation and again it
was well-rounded
the report considers the outline
application against the sustainability
of brad worley the site itself the local
plan the bluewood appeal and the nptf
the report notes the lack of any
objections from any technical quantity
it also notes only 12 objections from
the village plus the comments in the
parish council these have been
considered and robustly addressed in the
form
i understand the disappointment of the
objectives and the parish challenges we
got there
so more development than bad weather
than they had originally expected
however the proper weighting and balance
of policies as carried out by officers
shows that the proposed development and
the exceedance of those expectations
would not amount to a sound reason for
refusal
development on this northern edge of
bradworthy has also been established as
acceptableness appeal as noted in the
office report
noting the lack of continuous payments
and traffic levels hiring authority your
officers
and our highway consultants consider
that the site is within reasonable
walking distance and the conditions of
the village services those services that
make this a sustainable location and in
your local plan
the proposal would see the speed limit
reduced to 30 miles an hour new pavement
restricted whether it's non and the
provision of an access that meets
highway standards there are no highways
or transport reasons refusing
to create a suitable access two category
sea trees will need to be held one of
which already has sustained a large
group
there will be significant compensatory
tree and petrol planting significant
boosting as you've heard of the arbor
cultural and biodiversity value of the
land
as a result there are no arbor cultural
or ecological objections to the
development
the proposal will contribute up to 22
new values 30 of which would be
affordable including first homes as a
reduced market rate for local people
there would also be a suite of
contributions and on-site provisions as
required by the section 9-6
given there are no technical objections
to the development nor any sound policy
justification to one refusal i would
respectfully request that members follow
the advice of their professional
professional sorry for their planning
professionals and approve the
application thank you again
thank you
[Music]
well our final speaker to this is board
member
comes to the board
[Music]
in the middle of nowhere
that is exactly what it is a large
village it is not a town
and we want to try and keep it that way
and also because it's in the middle of
nowhere there is very limited public
transport
we're very fortunate gravity to have two
grocery stores
one of which includes a post office you
have a butcher hardware's hardware store
which all sells also sells furniture
plus another phone at a store we have a
garage plus two other businesses which
do vehicle repairs
we have a doctor's surgery veterinary
practice
a very very popular primary academy
and most important of all a very
well-rounded popular pub
we don't need any more houses to keep
these places sustainable because people
come from far and wide already to
support the law
this application site is outside as we
know it is outside of the boundary and
we're not normally being considered
we're not for the
field
i realized that the site deficit which
would refuse which would be confused
with their own appeal so it may well be
considered that the committee refused
this
if the committee refuses and it's like
that it would be 11 appeal i don't think
that's a reason to actually allow it
over the last couple of years i've
planned we have seen numerous similar
cases seeking permission for small
numbers of houses
of development boundaries in various
places a few here and a few there
some of which we've which have been
granted some of which have been refused
but this application is far larger than
any other one 22 houses it is
significant and it's in addition to all
the other houses in property
have been either grantable or when
they're in the system
now you can't blame the applicants for
trying let's basically wouldn't if they
own the same who
who wouldn't if they owned that field
thus you have to wonder if this is
granted how long would it be
before someone tries to develop a bit
further out of the village
on that basis i would urge the committee
to refuse his application
if nothing else but just to show
that we take the plans from if you take
seriously rather these concerns and also
um on all the parishes i represent it's
the same thing happens where parishes
feel that their their views aren't being
taken note off
thank you very much
thank you councilman
[Music]
that's the end of the
speakers so if james would like to
take your seat again
there's one chat
and could you show me
that's fine
that's okay then we're about just there
did
the inspector grab the five
uh so it's on the opposite side
basically yeah
uh
so it's opposite on the northern part so
um it's near the little buildings on the
right hand side yes correct yeah towards
the top of the slide i mean
[Music]
yeah that's fine so yeah so that is that
part of the site on that slide that says
holocaust cottage yeah that's the appeal
there and then the southern part of that
has also got um approval for
uh five dwellings as well you have the
right bargaining reserve matters of food
that was
[Music]
thank you um yeah a couple of things can
i just ask right has brand new only got
a neighborhood
and one of the things it does say it
says it needs to take into account
demographic changes
and i looked at this and i know this is
only outlined so well but it seems to be
just another load of ox stands in the
state house usually three barriers you
know and
i think it's about time this plan
committee actually started addressing
this
because in the 2011 census thirty
percent of households in britain and
singletons and it's gone up since then
yet
we still keep getting just these normal
mistakes
you know
we need to start stressing this
um i i welcome the 30 affordable but i
do know what the parish council say on
page 26 that bradley has 77 houses
that have been
given planning missions that haven't
been built i think 74 last time
it says
that
the agent working for this
applicant
this is the same one who's trying to
downgrade the number of affordable
housing on the other side
um i i know this was referred to i'd
like some extra detail on that because
this is a very important point of us
we all know well we all did the meeting
on tuesday on
thursday about envisioning our local
plans and future i think affordable
homes came top of everybody's list i
think we need to look at that um another
thing that does worry me and i did raise
this when we went in the cyclist the
attenuation point
i did ask who's going to maintain that
uh because there are only 22 houses here
now i've got very large estates in
business in my areas where
the people who live there they sign the
contract
to pay for the
facilities and the various attenuation
ponds and everything else but of course
we're talking you know states of 300
houses and you share the maintenance
plus between that 22 houses with a pond
that almost takes up a quarter of the
site
uh seems to be
really strange i wonder if
the parish council are aware that
you know you're going to get
people who will have to have quite a lot
of money to live there if they've got to
play all these charges which go up every
year
and i get constant complaints about them
and the last one
i was fascinated with your
incredibly exact figures from the
biodiversity game 57
and i'm just amazed by that can i ask
who actually checks
five years later after these estates are
built the biodiversity gain has actually
been gained
okay thank you
um i could take each of those questions
in turn really this one was about the
demographic so as you say really it is
in outline at the moment so we don't
know
um the precise makeup of of the
development in terms of the house sizes
but we've we've got a condition
suggested in your office's report which
is condition
16 and that deals with the housing mix
basically so what we've got in the
council is the head now which is from
2016 i think which sets out
um our evidence in terms of what we know
we need in terms of ones two three four
bedroom properties and so we always
negotiate on that basis really and sort
of
pretty much ensure that we stick to that
the outline um
outline stage is the correct stage to do
it in terms of that condition that
allows us to negotiate up when the
reserve might have stepped forward in
terms of the housing mix so we know that
we can negotiate on the basis of the
header which we know is the evidence
that underpins the need basically so so
i think it's reasonable that we always
get close to meeting that need really
because we're always going back to that
evidential base
um
on the
77 houses in terms of the affordable and
then the other site
i
understand it from i mean it's also
laura davies dealing with that oversight
as well the there is provision within
the planning system within the um
national uh the mppf and also the
practice guidance company and that that
people can or applicants can come in
with um viability information that sets
out that they can't afford um or the
development cannot deliver a policy
compliance scheme for whatever reason
maybe it's abnormal costs or something
like that the planning system requires
that as a council we we consider that um
that viability um assessment
and and act upon it accordingly really
and and that says really that if
if the level of contributions that we're
seeking will prevent development coming
forward then then effectively we do have
to look at reducing those unfortunately
and that's not something we want to do
or have to go back but it is
unfortunately something that's required
obviously
we now see the viability studies before
planning applications
uh accepted or rejected are you saying
that they can come back
after the agreement and rescinded
because that's the word that's used by
the parish council well they're trying
to rescind
something that was already agreed well
that's not correct because because
actually what we're dealing with is a
new application
so
what's been granted on that on that
other side is outline permission for 28
volumes the applicant has now come in
with a full application for 38 wellings
which has also been called in so in time
that application will come before
committee um to be debated by members
and and dealt with according to
everything as members state fair so
it's it's not correct that they're
trying to renegotiate up that previous
um outline in fact i think that the
previous academic commission would have
um
expired actually due to time
was there a viability study for this
particular scheme
for this one no because it is policy
compliance
with that
yeah thank you sorry to interrupt you no
it's fine
sorry do you want to continue yeah sure
um the other point was the attenuation
on the service charges yes i know that i
think
there is progress with southwest water
in terms of they do seem more um
[Music]
more willing and able to to adopt above
ground surface water features so that is
potential we're definitely seeing that
that they are taking those on but i do
know your point in terms of the service
charge if if cyclosport don't adopt it
but it would fall to the to the
residents of that scheme through the
management company basically
yeah the last point about biodiversity
uh biodiversity yeah sorry
so that's um
if
in terms of checking that there is a way
to do that and if members felt that it
gave comfort to them today then you
could request
or we could have a condition for a
landscape an ecological management plan
which would then set out
required details to come forward to the
council to be approved which would set
out how that
net gains actually monitors going
forward in the future so that's exactly
possible
thank you i think that's that's i think
we should follow that up actually
because we are getting more and more of
these there's going to be biodiversity
gain
oh great
you wonder would it actually achieve but
thank you for that
right well i've got a couple of points
here i think his members and everybody
knows it
i've always drawn everybody's
attention have nausea muscles once
outlined commissions granted
that's it it's been established that
that site can be developed
now looking at the affordable housing
statement they only speak of
possibly up to six 6.6 actually
affordable houses
and
my concern is with the outline
application i'll come to the other bits
to do the outline
and
how can we fix that at the outline stage
because this is for up to 22 it doesn't
say it's 428 up to 22. if this outlines
grantee what if they come forward with
the reserve matters for 10 dollars
well i think there's a couple points on
that you absolutely correct um in terms
of is up to 22 dwellings at the moment
um and so the section 106 of my members
were writing about commission would
secure 30 of those as affordable and
that would be a split of 75 um social
rents in 25 intermediate after potential
local grant policy that's fine
they they
the reason we can't fix that is
obviously because it's up to 22
dwellings so there is some uncertainty
about that but isn't it we're never
going to get to a point where we're
coming in for 10 and we'd approve that
because it would just represent an
inefficient use of the site really and
so the the up to 22 is more to account
for
small deviations really in terms of
maybe the attenuation pond needs to be
resized or maybe you need a bit more
open space or something like that and so
i think because
um there's obviously going to be a
desire from the applicant to maximize
the financial gain of that site really
as an asset so so i think it's logical
really that they will as much housing
will come forward as possible really and
so obviously that's a balance between
um the council checking that and being
um comfortable that the impacts are
acceptable but in terms of ten dwellings
come forward
basically i don't think that would
affordability there if there's only 10
plans being built you can't force them
to do 22. no we can't but we'll have
already secured through the 106 the 30
of whatever that is and that will
contain certain triggers within it in
terms of the delivery of that so what we
always ensure is when we negotiate the
106 we wouldn't leave the affordable
housing until the end of the development
because otherwise then there is a real
danger that development could build out
all the open market and then walk off
site never build these portables really
so we always make sure that the trigger
points are sufficiently um
forward in the development to make sure
that happens more before another chunk
of open market well
such answering that james and the other
thing i've got is
type of dwellings and you mentioned the
hebner
report that states the types of
dwellings needed in the torres district
area
and uh
i remember our planning manager said to
do with the site at gatton hill
that outlined stages have been fixed the
types of dwellings because when the
reserve matters came in
some of us wanted to see the bomber runs
on that site and change it and uh sean
told us that you can't it's been fixed
on stage so can we fix this narrative
and stage attack
come back on that chair so
yes
the reason for that at dallas was that
outline commissions by historic
commission a few years old and this is
the very purpose of this condition 16.
um the outline commission didn't have a
condition similar to condition 16 that's
proposed for members
and hispanism 16 then does allow us at
the dead matter stage to do that and
remember to consider that mix and the
uh different housing that they can
afford
thanks for answering that point john so
if you're reserved
we can
specify the types
okay
i think just to ask that really case law
suggests that you have to have that
condition on at this time
in terms of the outline otherwise you
in terms of diving
the way that works as well
you know you can't then just do it on
reserve matters unless you've got that
link back on the advantage a little bit
uh the other thing is on the western
boundaries proposed but new hedge
uh is that gonna be a different
vancouver
i'd like to see a devil back there
rather than just planting it all in the
yeah that's fine i think it would be
again um subject to the reserve matters
to the foreign part of the um
landscaping scheme but uh i know that
the case officer does refer to the um
bank within a report and i think it
when you gave the uh presentation of the
report
uh they're gonna cut their
bring their hedges cut the edges down
there to get the visibility space will
hedges then be replanted and back in
video yeah well i think the intention is
to try to locate that hedgerow um
which would be uh obviously just form
the visibility space but if there is any
loss then yeah it will need to be that
was supposed to be thanksgiving that was
supposed to have been happening
when
[Music]
and picking up on councillor christie's
point about
um viability that that's becoming with
many members of dirty work
because it seems every site comes
forward with a viability appraisal that
starts to whittle away the fact that we
can't put the
sixth affordable onsite and the
contribution for the point sits off side
but
as long as he's already known about the
cost of
this i mean
we've got the
affordability affordability
affordable housing statement here
contribution that's been required which
is nearly a hundred thousand
they know i did read somewhere about
offset provision and play to enhance the
play provisioning
i've not been able to find anything that
stands fingers for them no well i think
the way that played out the case officer
um contacted the parish council to see
if um
if there was any particular schemes
within bradley that would be um suitable
for um offside but i think from those
discussions
there wasn't really a firm um proposal
in that regard and therefore it was
difficult to
link that with the sale
regulations that we have to check for
windows
requirements so what we've gone down
instead is the 106 requires um all of
the provision to be on site basically um
which will obviously serve the needs of
those future occupiers
and also
the maintenance of those as well so
the um
the section 106 would secure an open
space scheme basically enough would
encompass all of those elements in terms
of vision the items of play equipment
and the maintenance of that as well and
the section 106 hasn't been concluded
yet has it no it's because it works
you won't be involved in them yeah
absolutely yeah as far as where those
discussions are
the other thing that's not mentioned or
financially cost so moving these traffic
signs up the road and
doing the necessary i can't think that's
going to be a great view maybe
give us some idea
yeah that's probably one command in
terms of liability
quickly i mean we just need something
called a traffic regulation
which comes in a region four thousand
pounds for a um for a small job like
this
so um
they shouldn't be too important
but
the likely
cost on cost really
um for developing this site so the level
thing
so we
personally i can't see any reasons why
as the latest stage of viability
appraisal should come forward and start
trying to whittle down the affordable
element obviously
yeah i mean certainly there's no
indication at the moment that there's
any viability issues with the site um as
we've seen this is a policy
position in terms of the level
contributions that that would be secured
by the 106. things can obviously prop up
in detailed design
stage in in abnormal costs but that
certainly has nothing to indicate that
at this stage and i would be surprised
if where they don't want
some kind of enhanced platform in there
for 22 hours
and the ones across the road are being
built yeah
i think this counselor when he spoke as
a board member
you know all this adds to the
infrastructure needed and necessary in
bandwidth and i'm sure that um perhaps
at the section one or six then that
might be raised yeah and i did see
something about a lot more
yeah so there would be a requirement for
um some allotment provisions that falls
under the council's green infrastructure
policy really which which encompasses
various types of green space green open
space and allotments as well so that
that will form part of the open space
scheme yeah
but it is obviously a question about
whether it's appropriate for that to
always be on site or whether it's more
appropriate to spend it offsite and to
contribute to a wider aim
i i i'm trying to agree with um
christie and
about the viability
that i i've seen outside and to me there
should be no
viability coming forward for that
because it's a beautiful flat side
you know and
the different bank situations straight
enough
off that side to put a diving bank up
anyway
but
after listening to it all
i'm gonna have to say
can we just confirm that
recommendation is in relation to the
additional condition of james
[Music]
yeah and then also potentially the the
um
landscape and ecological management
condition as well i think
members did want that included
yeah can we make that
condition
one that appears on every
application of those 10 houses or
something because i think it is
important yeah yeah sure yeah
[Music]
there we are
right nobody else wants to contribute to
sandra would you take the book because
it's been recommended for approval by
council watson
sorry thank you chair because
it's lebron
dancer christy or chancellor craigie or
cancer leather
or cancer watson
councillor wiseman
unanimous chair
thank you
[Music]
10 on page 60 is the delegated agmb
applications
there's one two three four five there
three places and two reviews
item 11
may generate planning decisions
for the period from the 22nd of october
to the 18th of november
on page 61.
62
63
page 64.
page 65
[Music]
page
66.
and 67
then 68
on page 69
three that were refused yeah
let's see i'm visiting
there's no excuse the public there's no
part two
so at
22 minutes past 10
i declared meeting